what do you think of the modern Tik Tok
style editing or like you know the very
fastpaced very like you you literally
need to grab your attention every
microsc uh I like it but I don't like
shorts okay it's weird okay so I like
the Mr Beast the new Mr Beast style
editing where he actually tells a story
he like hits the emotional beats not
just like oh Tik Tok after Tik Tok in 10
minute like compilation but I don't like
shorts themselves that like 60 seconds
cuz I don't know they're just annoying
to edit I I guess okay specific shorts
are fine if you like Conor films a
specific uh video just for shots that's
great cuz that's like a 60c video like
specifically made for it that's fine but
if it's like a highlights video that
needs to be compiled Too Short that's
like that's what I make you D but it's
so bizarre cuz sometimes I I I don't
understand what people want to watch and
why YouTube pushes people don't
understand what they want to watch I
still disagree with charts being a thing
sorry I disagree with shorts being a
thing cuz like you can get views from
shorts you can will get subscribers but
you will not get it will not translate
into long-term like VI it doesn't
translate to an audience yeah I mean the
discussion is up in the air right now
I'm like on the fence about it but I
think like if you want to make your
short successful you need to make it
with making shorts in mind you can't
it's it's never like I know there's like
a million [__] podcast clip that gets
like repackaged to shorts but me trash
taste you know [__] Subway Surfer at
the bottom that's it is it is I find it
from my personal experience cuz I get
recommended trash T Clips all the time
obviously I'm looking at it all the time
yeah I find it way easier to watch the
shorts than the clips yeah and I I will
admit that I think it's just a better
format for for short form Clips well
that's why every podcast now is doing
shorts right cuz I think they just
figured that out it's an easier way of
digesting uh digesting podcast I guess
it's like uh some sort of a banner
marketing cuz like when you have like
these banners pop on YouTube it doesn't
want you actually click on it it just
wants you to recognize the name like
Coca-Cola you're not going to click on
it you're going to be like oh Coca-Cola
maybe I'll have it later and that's the
same with charts you'll be like oh I've
seen him couple times like well you're
yeah that's what I think yeah that's
what I think it's more about just I I I
think that like getting just getting
eyes on it well yeah because then people
are going to keep if they keep seeing
you as a as a Creator or something
that's like the most important thing
because a lot of the time they just need
to recognize that that you're someone
that oh maybe I should watch this guy
yeah they'll be like who's this guy oh I
keep seeing this guy everywhere yeah for
sure um CU you know a lot of the times a
lot of YouTubers rely on sponsors and
sponsors want people or influencers uh
with recognizable faces or Brands right
and so having that kind of aware
awareness just it's not necessarily
about does the view translate to revenue
or growth in any capacity it's more like
okay you just need to become more your
face needs to be out there more right
yeah I don't know I weird weird weird
age it's it's a weird world now where
you know it's becoming more and more
like I guess old media and uh old like
just marketing tactics you know that's
pretty much his brand recognition just
getting your face out there smok camel
and malom cigarettes we're bringing back
the asbesto cigarettes guys turns out
it's actually good for you I should do a
short where I just try every cigarette
and just see if they actually taste
different is it true that not sponsored
but sponsored by the malor company is it
true that coke actually used to have
cocaine in it or is that imag yeah no it
used to have cocaine in it dude I wish I
could be boring we had in the in in the
like I think it was the 50s or 60s I
don't know which date it was with the
asbestos thing that was that was after
Coke was in Coke we thought to put
asbestos in cigarettes cuz Coke was a
normal thing back in the day like people
would have it like oh you're you're like
sick yeah have some cocaine it was like
an ointment yeah and then people get
like addicted we were born in the wrong
era no you act like tell God I legally I
that was a joke are you telling me I can
get Coke on the cheap well okay well
true true first of all must have been
lit in the uh second of all it's not
that hard to believe CU I mean look at
what's happened in America with the
opioid crisis right now it's obvious
that we haven't learned any lessons that
we're still going to prescribe and give
out stuff regardless of what effect we
we had the evidence now to know that it
would caus this and we still did it why
I don't [__] know we people will to
do it well big farm of money uh big farm
of money is powerful in America like
this is this is like real [__] let's
turn into a Joe Rogan I'm going to like
frogs are gay no wouldn't be talking
about big farmer he's talking about
which drug would taste best anal or
something you know what I mean like I
feel like this is the first conversation
people have before like you you fast for
10 years and like your flat earthers
now this is where it all went this is
the conversation I start like you can't
any dude actually dude I I will fact
check everything I'm going to tell the
story because there's no shot this guy
listens to this podcast I'll never find
out who this is um I go to this gym a
lot and there's a coffee shop that I
like to go to all the time on the way
back um and I I go there and I've seen
this guy who looks like 50 or 60 years
old I've seen him there maybe six or
seven times now I when I go in the
morning only in the early morning uh and
I've never spoken to him um and so this
time he came up to me and he spoke to me
uh and uh he goes hey man you live in
Japan I was like yeah man just I live
not too far from here uh and uh he's
like oh cool cool what are you from I
was like from Wales he like Wales nice
place uh I used to live in China but I
live in Japan now I was like oh cool
cool I was like um where you from it's
California I was like oh I go to
California all the time I like it it's
great he's like well it's not as good as
it used to be and I was like oh okay
what do you mean by that he's like well
you know the Liberals kind of took over
and changed it I was like [__] head I
was like yeah yeah okay what do you what
do you that's the moment where your
brain just instantly shots off I was
like and I was like I was like okay well
okay sure man well yeah I mean he's like
yeah well I used to live in China but
you know the experiments with the bats
and all that I just didn't want to be
there
and I was like I was like okay that's
fine that's fine he's like and then he I
don't know how this even it was even
prompted he just goes well yeah you know
I just I just think that uh I just think
that the president right now by the way
I voted for Obama he said that I like a
as a way to like bear in mind this whole
time I've just been nodding that's like
the equivalent of I have a black friend
by the way but yeah and he's like he's
like I just think I just think right now
I just think that Trump will get it done
and I was like okay that's fine like I I
don't [__] care what you're political
leing all just don't do this to people
why are you opening up with this
especially when it's unprompted yeah I
didn't ask I didn't ask I don't care I
do not care I did not ask I am wait I'm
literally just praying that my coffee
will be ready in a moment so I can leave
uh and of course when I get my coffee he
won't let me leave he's just talking me
I was like man so who did you vote for I
to stop him and be like and yeah he goes
on about brexit and stuff and I was like
he's hitting all the greatest hits I'm
like leave me alone I want to go yeah
but um why why did I bring this up again
uh want to tell a story yeah I think
this was just cuz I met like a crazy
person not a crazy person but one of
those people uh I guess wait what the
[__] were we saying before this we were
talking about uh health benefits no we
were that's way far back no we were
talking about like old media coming back
no no no no no we were talking about we
I the dienal risk is kicking in 1% can I
take a piss
sure while I trying to figure out what
the [__] we were talking about we were
talking about [__] why did I bring this
up I had a good reason shorts and then
we were talking about [__] Mudan bring
up the footage M bring it up bring it up
oh [__] he's over there um there was a
reason why flat earthers that's it flat
earthers dude it's like you you will
just come across people no matter where
you are in the world and they will seem
totally chill and you let you let them
talk to you for five minutes and you'll
just realize the only thing that's
changed is that people who who we used
to consider like kind of out there are
like are so good at being normal and
just waiting for the opport to say
they're good at just waiting like they
know they okay not to I don't refer to
them as crazy people CU I think that's
unfair and that's that's not that
doesn't help situation when you call
them crazy but like people with
alternative beliefs are very good now at
knowing and they they try to sus out
people who they think will like not
reciprocate what and and I think they
because I I think I attract these people
um cuz every Uber ride I will I will
never stop them from talking cuz I just
so fascinated to hear I love hearing
every time I get in an Uber with you
I've never seen the Uber driver be that
chatty well cuz I'll prompt them and
they're not and they're not talking to
me cuz I got my headphones well cuz I
prompted them like we had that guy in
Florida one time I was about to say the
Florida guy it was this course it was a
Florida guy but it was a Ukrainian guy
uh who was in in Florida I was saying
how I I I attract I'm I'm I can sus out
when people are going to say these weird
stuff and I always let them talk cuz I
always want to hear what they're going
to say because I think I think that like
to understand how these people work I
need to like understand like where
they're coming from and so I'm always
just kind of like yeah yeah maybe you're
right I just say stuff like that and
then just kind of prod them and keep
telling them uh this yeah guy in Florida
who is he was insane he yeah he bro he'd
been he'd been he'd been uh he'd been
watching a lot of news uh he'd been
having strong opinions about Trump
watching a lot of fox yeah a lot of fox
opinions very interesting very
interesting I mean sometimes you talk
someone and like I have you ever had a
point where you've talked to someone and
you know it's kind of like you hear a
line and you're like oh yeah I know
immediately I like you definitely you
definitely heard this from a podcast or
something this you've definitely been on
Reddit a bit too long well it's because
they they generally people who with
these types of beliefs will say one line
that is very like uh um non-committal to
their opinion and they'll see how you
react to it but it's so easy to sus out
when they're doing this like I voted for
Obama by the way well well like when you
said like well when he said like uh like
California is not as good as it used to
be yeah like that's just such a like
subtle way of like trying to sus out why
you stand on that's that's when you hear
the vsource music you know like he's
about to go off about something I'll be
like oh man how so yeah and then and
then he'll say this crazy thing I crazy
to me I mean some of it is just insane
but sometimes they'll say something and
I'm like man yeah I guess I got
something to think about yeah I'm going
to go home like [__] never talking to
that guy again Jesus Christ yeah like I
I I think I had like the exact same
moment at a party I was at like when I
was when I was in America uh in the
midwest by the way that's bro for oh oh
of course uh yeah so you know I was I
was at this uh random I was at this
random party uh that you know had a
bunch of like you know it's you know
when you're at a party and you get
invited because a guy knows a guy and uh
you know you you're invited there but
you don't really know anyone there so my
least favorite kind of parties so you
know I was there because some of uh some
of like uh Sydney's brother's old
friends were there but you know it was
kind of like a [__] massive party you
so they didn't know everyone there uh so
I was just kind of like sussing out the
vibe of some people and the thing about
America I've I've I've like noticed is
that you go to a party and sometimes you
do not know what kind of like the vibe
or the people you're surrounded with are
going to be like you know um and so you
know you I was talking I was talking to
this random guy and I can't remember we
got on the topic of like relationships
uh just cuz I mentioned I was married
and stuff like that and he was like oh
how how is that going you are you
happily married I'm like yeah and I just
asked are you like in a relationship or
anything like that and he's like no no
I'm I'm I'm saving myself and so I was
like oh so I assumed it must be like a
religious thing right and then uh he I
was like it's this was the line where he
was like no I've been a I've been
waiting for a virgin because you know I
think that vir was he an idol fan no no
I I think that just virgins are the way
to go I think once you lose your
virginity the woman just become lower
value and I'm like this is this is a
[__] Andrew T listener like I I it
was the first how do you respond to
that yeah how do I respond I was like oh
cool this the exact kind of person I'd
love to talk to I would love I would
love to be like just just tell me more
about it what do you think about that
you know some people might say that
that's a that's a bigoted way of looking
at it what what do you think about
that oh cuz like I you know talking to
the guy he's exactly the type of guy he
was like as much of like a typical frat
boy as you could like imagine like kind
like that kind of like image uh it was
just the first time that I had so
obviously met someone who had been
influenced by let's say the podcasting
era of things where where you you hear
verbatim a line that you've heard on
some random Tik Tok that has been
recommended for you you know cuz lot of
these guys are just they're just like
hey my life's not going the way I wanted
it to this guy just told me that it's
all women's fault and now I guess that
that's how I'm going to live my life and
believe that just my belief now yeah
yeah was it like in Estonia huh is it
fun in Estonia making friends talking to
people crazy people we don't talk to
anybody it's like the North or you go up
there that less people talk to you yeah
like if you're in America people talk to
you on a bus in uh like Europe you'll
get
shanked it's like hi there like don't
talk to random people it's weird like
they'll instantly think you look like
crazy or something yeah that does happen
I think it's a very British as well do
not just approach people in public that
is just a big no no yeah for sure do you
think the average trash Tes listener
instead of like quoting some very
opinionated political opinion just just
starts quoting like shitty food takes is
that how you tell like a trash it
happens just be had a party and they be
like I hate Crossing or pizza by the way
D and then they like oh God which
podcast did you hear that from
huh I I've been to ax people randomly
come up like oh hey Muran they just
randomly start talking about the food
takes yeah like wait what do they say to
you oh no I like oh I like uh the
boneless chicken or I like bone in or
stuff like that like I didn't ask all
right that's that's great for you yeah
sick Bro oh you don't like bread as well
all right sick no you you only eat bread
and pasta and rice yeah well I don't
care I eat
everything you just said you just eat
rice and just pasta no that was like
like [__] seven years ago what are
you now everything you like everything
what's what's your favorite
cyanid I
wish no I I guess I've uh become more
like you where it's like Uber Eats is
cheaper uh to be more productive like
making food the amount it takes like you
go to the store you buy and you make see
I'm not lazy mhm well Japan is so cheap
no wonder you [__] get everything I I
I try to tell people this dude when I
when you Uber Eats in America right it's
ridiculous you you you will order a
lunch it'll be like $15 by the time you
get it you've paid $35 somehow yeah yeah
[__] shipping here 50s to have like
all breeds here yeah you and often the
restaurants don't mark up so a lot of
the times you would just pay the normal
amount I I have no idea who's making
money and just someone's losing money in
this thing the overall food here is like
half the price as in Europe pretty much
yeah most of my Uber meals come to
around $10 which is what I would pay if
I went out and just like got it anyway
exactly so for me it's like it I mean it
sounds lazy and I I absolutely is but I
love it and the fact that I can pay $10
and get a meal delivered to my door
that's good and and healthy and great
quality is like this is [__] the UK
could never UK absolutely could never I
most countries could never uh yeah I'm
very lazy yes and I mean Japan's always
been cheaper to eat out anyway you know
yeah so you know that that image of like
the soldiers holding up the world and
there like a mom and a kid there's
literally the Uber delivery drivers in
Japan they are holding up Japan right
now they they are holding up this
economy de ass no it's like them and
like I heard there's like a shortage of
like Japanese bus drivers or something
now I don't know if this is yeah there's
a routin chba that used to run 60 times
a day and now it's down to seven you
have bosses yeah we have bosses but
there's also like also taxi drivers uh
and Kyoto have gone down I think 25%
this year and they need more damn um so
yeah there's a but they've started
hiring some FM St hang foreign taxi
drivers oh really I'm just going to say
it all right I don't think I don't think
that the the this quality uh of Japanese
taxi driver is that good that only
Japanese taxi drivers can do the job of
course it's not like in London where
they're trained to like they have to
learn every single Street in Japan
you're like hey can I go here and he's
like what is Tokyo Station well half the
time they just like oh okay I don't know
where that is use the GPS all of them
use the GPS and also I would prefer them
to use the GPS because a lot of the
times when they I think 50 I don't know
not 50% like there's a good chance if
they go by memory that they [__] it up
oh yeah so I'm just like can you I
always ask them to use the GPS uh cuz
I'm like just please please go here
please yeah I always just tell them put
in this address yeah so I feel like
there's no there's no need for them to
gep you about it just let the let the
let the let's Steve from Wisconsin Drive
the cabs I'll I'll I'll do it